I'm supposed to make introductory
remarks on turning kosher I was making
directory remarks I most of it down at
some point it'll become very apparent
that I'm kind of winging it but the
Edward M Kennedy Prize for drama
inspired by American history from its
inception has been in part about
struggling to define things which is to
say struggling to understand things and
exercise which always brings you in
touch with the power of understanding
and also its limits the usefulness
indeed the necessity of attacking
definitions and the impossibility of
getting reality to obey one's
definitions
maybe all prizes are like that since
after all all prizes are about judging
one of our earliest and most defining
and I think best decisions in creating
and implementing the emk prize through
its first five years of operations was
made when we were confronted with a
difficulty of arriving at a definition
of history Jean Kennedy Smith the emk
Prizes founder and the mother of us all
knew that to honor her brother's legacy
of profound commitment to an engagement
with the ongoing life of our democracy
this would be a prized recognizing
American drama both plays and musicals
that were inspired by confronted
addressed or addressed American history
which immediately raised the question of
what history is the decision made in
that early moment was to be guided by
genes spirit of open-hearted open-minded
unforced generosity the mkay prizes
definition of history attempts to
recognize the absurdity of attempting to
pinpoint and then police the borderline
between past and present that boundary
like all boundaries is dynamic shifting
reformed and remade not just by the
vicissitudes of historical events but by
ascent by in a sense history itself
nothing is more susceptible to the
passing of time than our relationship to
time we hope to offer our nominators in
our judges a mandate to rediscover every
year what history means based on what's
happening in the world around them and
on the materials at hand the plays and
musicals Americans have produced in any
given year I don't think it occurred to
us till this year's deliberations there
was another word in the emk prizes
expansive official title that might at
some point require definition or at
least the considered acknowledgement of
the difficulty of defining
and we knew what we we knew that we
wanted drama to include plays in
musicals
senator Kennedy Jean explained to me at
our first meeting life plays but he
really loved musicals and as the
recipient of last year's the MK Prize
demonstrated some of the best dramatic
works in American history about American
history have been musicals in all
dramatic worked as a complicated
relationship between text and staged
event the MK prize is awarded on the
basis of the play as text or the musical
as text and score one of the few limits
we place on our judges is a preclusion
of considering production production in
judging the finalists
this year's recipient the 24 decade
history of American popular song
challenges all defining boundaries
including genre it is a text it's a so
we're calling it a play my I brought
evidence here it is it's three hundred
and eighty three pages long including
the lyrics to two hundred and forty six
songs
it's an astonishing astonishing read as
our judge is discovered and as everybody
on the board who had the chance to read
it discovered it was performed earlier
this season once for a relatively small
about six hundred Hardy and extremely
fortunate few when it was selected it
wasn't clear to the judges or to the
board whether a twenty four decade
history will be performed again as
24-hour twenty four-hour performance
whether it can be performed by others or
if the text will in fact be made
available to others through publication
it wasn't even clear whether or not its
creators considered it a text but we did
with only after the judges made their
choices that we realized that we'd never
specified in our bylaws that a recipient
work needed to be performed more than
one speery performer by other people or
be published and on further reflection
we decided that we've been very wise to
leave out these requirements since it
made possible by stowing this year's
prize on what is an astounding text the
basis of what was clearly
one of the great nights of theater since
Judy at Carnegie Hall or Aeschylus one
of the other things that we decided
early on this was actually my
campaigning is that drama critics would
never be allowed anywhere near this
prize not to judge it not if any of you
are here in the room you snuck in and
you'll be taken care of later but I'm
going to read a little bit of a review
this is by a movie critic by Wesley more
of the New York Times so he's not a
drama critic so it's like one step up on
the evolutionary chain
he writes mr. Mack gave me one of the
great experiences his review of 24
decade history mr. Mack gave me one of
the great experiences of my life I've
slept on it and I'm sure it wasn't the
physical feat so come on 246 songs
spanning 240 years for 24 straight hours
including small breaks for him to eat
hydrate and use the loo and starting in
1776 and ending in 2016 with mr. Mackall
doing original songs on the piano and
ukulele he remembered all the lyrics and
most of Walt Whitman's song of myself'
and he sang them in every imaginable
style at every tempo with every possible
facial expression in every register his
handsome protein voice the 24 decade
project was at least in part about
becoming who we want who we Americans
want to be by recognizing who we have
been it's about artistic confrontation
reinterpretation and personal
transcendence the scope of the project
allows you to consider the centuries of
artistic ghosts we live with mr. Max
tagline was a radical fairly very
realness ritual off to its right was a
napping loss and at some point sleeping
bags were distributed but a lot of us
managers managed to stay awake for most
if not all of this event so if you paid
the price of admission which also seemed
to include so you paid the price of
admission which also seemed to include a
night of dreamless nosov course might
have been the point what if some of
America's trouble is that we've been too
caught up in our own individual dreams
that some dreams mean
nightmare for somebody else what if mr.
max Fantasia was the anti dream and
those 24 beautiful hours were about the
wisdom of staying woke so we're so
thrilled to have mr. max mr. ray here
tonight and to be presenting you with
the Everton Canada Prize it's now my
distinct pleasure to hand stage over to
two friends of mine one of the
traditions in presenting the Kennedy
prize oh and and then so we're the film
the okay is this a wonderful documentary
a short documentary about Senator
Kennedy then I'm flying to London right
after this I'm blushing not here
basically then because as I said senator
Kennedy really loved musicals every year
since the first year of the prize
we've asked someone from the theatre
world to come and sing as part of the
ceremony about a month ago or think of
an into whose Oh aduba on the subway
she's an absolutely extraordinary
actress many of you know her from is the
new black and her stage work and we met
in the 42nd Street subway station and
then I called her and asked if she would
come and do this for some reason I don't
know why she said yes so she's here and
she's going to be doing a musical
entertainment then my good friend and
one of America's genuinely great
novelists Michael Cunningham told me I
think last summer that he planned to see
the entire 24-hour performance I was out
of town I didn't get to see it so I
called Michael and said you saw it
you're one of the few people that
actually got to so come and talk about
it every year we have someone speak
in-depth about the work and Michael has
agreed to do that so now I'm going to
sit down and here's the film
[Applause]
that which we are we are one equal
temper of heroic hearts and will to
strive to seek to find and not to yield
for all those whose cares have been are
concerned the work goes on the cause and
doors the hope still lives and the dream
shall never die
[Music]
no matter who writes the history books
when people look back on this century
they will say that Edward Kennedy was
one of the ablest and most productive
most compassionate and most effective
men who started in the United States
Senate in the entire history of the
country my father loved this country and
was fascinated by the men and women who
helped to shape its history whenever he
felt the need to better understand an
issue he often looked back to how others
had solved similar problems
he loved historical documents and
biographies their perspective helped him
gain understanding not only of their
time but of our own Abe Lincoln was a
quiet and a melancholy man but when he
spoke of democracy this is what he said
he said as I would not be a slave so I
would not be a monster this expresses
my idea of democracy whatever difference
from this to the accept of the
difference is no democracy
and welcome my grandmother
Rose Fitzgerald Kennedy gave tours of
her home in Hyannis Port yeah it's a
very charming little picture of Ted with
the child at the Embassy again very
serious who and a wonderful round of the
president's late President Roosevelt a
tradition my father followed giving
tours of his office at Jamie Wyatt like
Grandma he could narrate our nation's
history from an extraordinary point of
view architecture President Kennedy and
the dog tags that he's wearing in the
Pacific my father wanted to make history
come alive
he created the annual family history
camping trip he packed up all of my
cousins and took us on trips to visit
famous American sites in the company of
historians a senator Kennedy has been
taking his nieces and nephews and many
of his family to historic places year
after year
it's a wonderful family tradition it
ought to be a family tradition
everywhere because those trips can
change your life he took us to Plymouth
in the south shore the homes of
Nathaniel Hawthorne and Herman Melville
in the Berkshires Paul Revere and
Longfellow house the Freedom Trail the
USS Constitution the Brooklyn Bridge
Harpers Ferry Manassas Mount Vernon Fort
McHenry and a church in Richmond after
senator Kennedy's most recent visit
where Patrick Henry made his famous
speech Ted nearly tackled me on the
Senate floor the next week to tell me
about it and how exciting it was to him
and and to the members of this family
I insist that every child is going to
develop a love of history or an
understanding but be sure can do
everything we can to give an opportunity
for the young people his love of
American history and his place in it is
treasured by our family but his
contributions to celebrating and
preserving our history is his lasting
gift to all Americans my brother Edward
Moore Kennedy was the last of my mother
and father's nine children right from
the start he captured our attention my
mother had an insatiable interest in
history literature in the arts and she
taught and quizzed each of us about what
she thought was important
mother required Teddy to memorize the
poem the midnight ride Paul Revere she
felt that longfellows poem was a
wonderful way for her children to learn
about poetry and history at the same
time listen my children and you shall
hear of the midnight ride of Paul Revere
on the 18th of April in 75 hardly a man
is now alive who remembers that famous
day and year teddy always said that
early exposure to our nation's history
and literature had an immeasurable
impact on his life an avid reader of
biographies he orthotist own true
compass as well as several others
including a children's book and how laws
are made it's told through the eyes of
his beloved dog splash he admired the
visual arts and was an accomplished
painter who shared his work with friends
and family music was perhaps dearest to
him a gift from our grandfather honey
Fitz and our mother attended you know
singing sweet Adeline I used to play for
him on this piano
[Music]
Kenny and I shared an enjoyment of
theater
especially for Hume use achill theater
he admired the discipline and skilled a
theater demanders of actors directors
and writers he was intrigued by the
theaters creation of worlds based on the
human imagination either for the
purposes of escaping was difficult at
night or for the purposes confronting
difficult truths he loved the creative
community and the feeling was mutual he
was an ardent student of American
history and of course he devoted his
life to public service for over 40 years
in the United States Senate he
championed the role of the arts and
humanities and the promotion of our
culture life is integral to the American
experience Teddy could have done
anything with this life and so he chose
to do everything we are all the better
for it
[Applause]
hello everyone and welcome I'm Ted
Kennedy jr. and thank you so much to
Columbia University and to all of you
for joining in this special awards
ceremony this afternoon in honor of
Taylor Mac and Matt ray for their for
their performance a twenty four twenty
four decade history of popular music a
radical fairy realness ritual and we are
so proud to be here to award the 2017
Edward M Kennedy Prize for drama
inspired by American history - two
outstanding artists in our country to be
honest with you I couldn't believe my
years when I heard the news that that
you two were going to be the award
recipients this year Taylor and Matt are
such unique choices for this prize their
selection really shatters our mental
boundaries of how our country's history
and culture is conveyed through artistic
expression
I love the selection committee for
recognizing these two amazing artists
among the very accomplished group of
finalists so please join me in thanking
the nominators and the incredible
committee that serves the award this
incredible prize so
my father my father would have loved
tailor and match and that's edgy
artistry and and their love of history
and and their country but I want to make
a special tribute to my aunt Jean who
created this prize in honor of my father
you know my father was known as the Lion
of the Senate and a voice of the
powerless and a huge supporter as you
saw in the video of the National
Endowment for the Arts something that is
under threat today and and as a fighter
for social justice and for tolerance and
I'm very proud that he was one of our
country's first leaders to call gay
rights the final frontier of our
struggle for civil rights for all
Americans but thank you to Jean dad
thank
thanks to you Jean dad will also be
remembered as an artist and as a
historian who desperately wanted to make
art in history accessible to students
and new audiences who never knew that
they loved history and so he loved
spending his free time with his friends
who were artists and they were such
great company and they reminded him to
keep a perspective on everything he did
with his life and and about the things
in life that were really important
he loved their friendship and and they
loved him so Jean you and Dad had such a
special bond and I am so grateful that
you decided to honor dad in this special
way now I first met Taylor Mac I had the
privilege of attending one of his
performances at the International
Festival of Arts and ideas in New Haven
Connecticut just last year I know that
there are many people here in the
audience today it came down from New
Haven to be part of this celebration and
and Taylor premiered his
his 1990s decade of the 24 decade
concert of songs and commentary in New
Haven at the festival now I didn't know
anything about Taylor Mac my wife
usually she's on the festival board my
wife Kiki she gets all the tickets and
she just said you'll love the show and
whatever and I had heard that Taylor was
a music musician and a storyteller and a
drag queen and I didn't know what to
expect and of course he appeared on
stage with his band and he was wild and
colorful and sparkling sparkling makeup
and body paint and wearing high heels
and I almost lost my mind he and when he
said where are my lesbians referring of
course to his backup singers I knew I
was going to be in for a very
entertaining show needless to say the
performance was electrifying and
provocative and he's been described as a
musician and a poet and now you are you
are going to be known as a historian of
American history so I got a little
nervous I did get a little nervous when
he said he warned the audience this is
we come to the part in the show where
people are going to start walking out
and and of course you know I was at that
point a newly elected official in the
state of Connecticut and I turned to my
wife and I said do you think I can be
seen here
and and but did honestly the experience
just took all of us out of our comfort
zones and stretched our minds which is
exactly what the arts should do so that
Ray you are an incredibly accomplished
musician performer and collaborator
thank you too for bringing American
history to life and for him enhancing
our understanding of the American
experience
make hiss and making history fun
interesting and accessible and again to
tony kushner who's the spiritual had it
and leader of this prize and
collaboration with my aunt and all the
people who are here today thank you all
for coming here and celebrating this
incredible celebration of my father's
life and to amazing artists of our
country
[Applause]
congratulations Taylor and Matt you've
been on my mind or sister with two of a
kind
Oh sister I'm keeping my eyes on you I
bet you think I don't know nothing Oh
sister well I got news for you I'm
something and I hope you think that
you're something too oh now now
scuffling I'll bring up that Lonesome
Road and I've seen a lot of
Suns going down Oh
but trust me
ain't no lowlife gonna run me around no
so let me tell you something - recess
booked your name no wisdom gonna steal
myself away ah we show ain't got a whole
lot of time no so shake yeah
shimmy sister hug is feeling
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
and only cool water we repair time I
don't ask you to treat me like I'm not
asking for friendly conversation I'm not
asking for Paris
all I'm asking for is change hate me but
don't kick my come I wear your
kindness begin please both do not spend
time with me I don't ask you to treat me
like your mother
no I'm not asking for sympathy
[Music]
all I'm asking for is just
strange to go to misspell some bail it's
not fair out like the leathers painted
from the mater what we are just need
money to buy more drugs and if you folks
pay people walk by me with glee because
I am what they'll never be I don't ask
you to keep your hat
I don't ask notice what I'm wearing no I
could care less about things like
all I'm asking for is cha
[Music]
penny on nickel ha
we inhale roll up
[Music]
[Laughter]
Hey
[Applause]
Oh God
I can't sing for walk in heels here
comes the death of fun I was among the
hundreds who attended Taylor Max and
Matt Ray's 24 decade history of popular
music a radical fairy realness ritual
which Taylor and Matt performed for 24
hours straight
in early October at st. Ann's warehouse
in Brooklyn I can tell you that I not
only stayed the entire 24 hours but
actually would have stayed longer I can
tell you that if we're all well advised
to employ the phrase life-altering
experience as sparingly as possible i
unhesitatingly spend one of my limited
supply of that phrase on Taylor and Matt
being present Etha performance was
purely and simply a life altering
experience now my only problem is I've
got to convey to you some sense in a
relatively short period of a theatrical
phenomenon that would be hard to express
in well 24 hours during the performance
at st. Anne's Taylor said jokingly but
more than once this is going to go on a
lot longer than you're going to want it
to I'm no Taylor Mac still consider
yourselves warned
now I'm going to start with the review
with a quote from the review and the
Guardian journalist being so much better
at brevity the novelists The Guardian
said clearly we have never been in more
need of mass and raise radical fairy
realness ritual which in 246 songs and
24 hours will replace the sick straight
America we know and loathe with a deeply
queer one in which outcasts and
outsiders are recognized as venerated
and venerated as visionaries responsible
for creating the country's culture Yeah
right as Taylor himself put it - at the
beginning of the show we have a lot of
history on our backs and we have to
figure out what to do with it I hope
you'll forgive me if I quote myself as
well I went to the show with five
friends and we all stayed the full 24
hours none of us slept at all and once
I'd gotten home a little letter to the
five others I needed to preserve the
experience we just shared and I needed
to address the letter to fellow
witnesses the 24 decade history had been
so vast and various that I could feel
fragments of it already sparking out
along my neural pathways on the way home
from st. Anne's not because there have
been any unmemorable intervals but
because the human brain some human
brains more than others can retain only
so much I read The Guardian review
before I wrote the letter
The Guardian piece was not only a
brilliant appreciation but a remarkable
distillation of what had occurred during
those 24 hours and yet as I wrote in my
own letter you know the cardian did a
fine job of choosing
examples but there were at least a
hundred other astounding moments each of
which was worth the price of admission
all by itself I realize that when I tell
people about it I'll have to edit like
crazy for anybody who wasn't there
because although I'd like to tell others
about all the high points all the actual
miracles I can't really ask anyone to
sit still and listen to me for as many
hours as that would take don't worry
there were literally hundreds of
climaxes some of them performances on
stage and some performances among or
involving the audience I'm not
exaggerating like most novelists I'm
generally prone to exaggeration when I
say that although we surely all had
favourites that was literally not a dull
moment in the entire 24 hours musical
number by musical number scene by scene
costume by costume we were given a
riveting fiercely political queer eyed
history of America an American capable
of greater ecstasy's and evils that we
might have imagined and America we may
not have fully known we knew about until
we had it tumbled out for us most of the
song so remember there were two hundred
and forty six of them remember to the
tailor was on stage the entire time and
Matt for twenty-three of the 24 hours
were accompanied by performances dances
many involving members of the audience
and I'm not sure what to call them let's
just say there was a boxing match
between Walt Whitman and Stephen Foster
stand-ins there was a Civil War battle
fought with ping-pong balls by two
randomly chosen factions of the audience
and around 6:00 a.m. when we'd been
there 12 hours there was the sudden
appearance of a marching band that
paraded cacophonous Lee up one aisle
played move on up on stage
braided back out along another aisle and
were not seen or heard again
what of all that should you most
urgently relay to the people who happen
not to be there what should you omit the
Guardian chose quote a naked prison sex
scene that ensures the Connie Francis is
where the boys are will never be heard
quite the same way again you keep me
hanging on by the Supremes
which in Max and Ray's version is sung
by an imaginary bus of gay people going
to support the civil rights movements
1963 march on Washington brings sudden
tears even more overwhelming is Max and
Ray's take on Elton John's goodbye
yellow brick road in which for audience
members there another member aloft on
their shoulders symbolizing Judy
Garland's funeral all true all
remarkable but what about how this is me
again what about the production of The
Mikado set on Mars by way of taking the
racism of Gilbert and Sullivan's
original to its farthest and most
perversely logical extreme what about
Roy Orbison's pretty woman accompanied
by a thousands of strippers women and
men evoking the dirty glamour of the
1950's what about the queer junior prom
when we in the audience were asked to
dance with someone of our own assigned
gender while carolers sang a swoony
version of Ted Nugent's heavy metal
number snakeskin two Cowboys in order to
as Taylor put it metaphorically kill the
viciously right-wing Ted Nugent what
about Taylor calling the oldest audience
member a man in his 80s to the stage and
then the youngest an 18 year old girl
saying to the older man start dancing
and to the girl follow his moves what
about the fact
the older guy could really dance that
the girl matched him move pramook what
about the heartbreaking beauty of that
so many more but I'm afraid I'm wearing
you out already
Carolyn and math show like many
significant works of art can't really be
conveyed if you weren't actually present
for it I hope that doesn't sound
exclusionary it's merely true most of us
missed the premiere of Rite of Spring -
and larette Taylor's and Loretta
Taylor's performance in the first
production of The Glass Menagerie as I
wrote to my five friends it's as if
we've been kidnapped by
extraterrestrials have returned safely
to find that everyone believes our story
but no one except us was there with us
and so we encounter real limits as to
how the experience can be communicated
you know the image of kidnapped by
extraterrestrials isn't such a bad one
as analogies go something impossible has
happened to you and although you
returned in calf to your own zip code in
your own bed you're not quite the same
person you were when you found yourself
being sucked upward by Bheema light I
went out for cigarettes at some point
during the night after about five or six
blocks and was astounded to realize that
for most people it was just another
Saturday night people are going to bars
going to restaurants it it seemed
impossible how could they not know that
a dimensional warp had opened right
there in the neighborhood how could they
fail to know that at that very moment
mere blocks away a troop of ukulele
strumming Tiny Tim's was engaged in a
dance-off with a chorus of man dressed
as James Joyce's Ulysses
which was somehow convincingly part of a
tribute to the over 16 million who died
in World War one I'll stop now if I'm
the only one in the room who feels like
this roof was too short scandalously
short sketchy embarrassingly
insufficient it's a tribute to the
immense and fabulous parallel universe
the ferocious and annihilating the
gorgeous and tawdry a miraculous
American dream of itself the tailor and
map created as New York Times put it
normally he's a star this weekend he was
a solar system I closed the letter to my
friends by saying with all I've written
I'm afraid there's still something about
it that can't really be explained not
even among ourselves or rather at any
rate that's explaining it is beyond me
hundreds of people felt it I'm still
recovering sweet dreams my love
blessings on us all finished letter hit
send get up from your desk and resume
your slightly altered deeply enriched to
life Thank You Taylor and Matt Thank You
Columbia thank you ted kennedy blessings
on us all as all right hear this one
thank you
[Applause]
this is a story of my life following
Tony Krishna you and you're up first
we're children I read this really
well-organized the Edward M Kennedy I
think we know the Edward n kennedy Prize
for drama inspired by American history
is given annually to a new player
musical then in this status power to
explore the past of the United States to
participate meaningfully the great
issues of our day through the public
conversation grounded in historical
understanding that is essential to the
functioning of a democracy does anybody
here think that I actually wrote that
the Board of Governors of the pride
wants to thank our panel of
distinguished judges playwrights amy
Hertzog Robert O'Hara Kate Moreau Ryan
and taeksoo Scott Wilson playwright and
librettist here Alegria Buddhist
composer in Monti and Zuri professions
of she'd khalidi and James Shapiro and
Carol Becker skiing at the Columbia
University's School of the Arts two
pages are stuck together hold on we're
doing so well oh yeah
okay I'm going to I'm going to movies
that's it
national okay a national network of 20
theatre professionals selected five
extraordinary place to be finalists at
the 2017 Kennedy prize row by Lisa bloom
are produced by Oregon Shakespeare
Festival Berkeley rep and Arena Stage a
twenty four decade history of popular
music a radical fear that carry realness
ritual by Taylor Mac and Matt ray
produced by pomegranate Arts and
nature's darlings sweat by Lynn Nottage
produced by the Oregon Shakespeare
Festival he had gone by Klee and
produced by the self myself miss
repertory and decent by Paula Vogel
produced by Yale Repertory Theater I'm
not going to read this I'm not going to
read the panel decision the prize
committee has chosen Taylor max a Mac
raised a 24 decade history of popular
music a radical fairy realness as the
twenty seventeenth winner of the Edward
M Kennedy prize a vast immersive
subversive audacious and outrageous
theatre experience did you write that
Roger very the twenty four decades
history employs a variety of performance
technique techniques to illuminate and
explore a country's history as seen
through the lens of its popular music
this piece shows in max words how in
America the oppressor is forgiven but
the outsider is still aside Taylor and
Matt would you please come up
Oh
[Applause]
well thank you all very much I don't
thank you yes it's a real honor that we
get the prize because of the name
because Ted Kennedy was a public servant
and I I look to public public servants
to make my work I'm inspired by them
more than I am artists and I try to make
work that is a public service and
especially in this particular piece so
that's what we we set out to do and
hopefully it will help inspire us to do
more so thank you very much well I'm
normally an improviser but I felt like I
wanted to write something just because I
figured my mind might go blank
especially since I'm holding this cheque
which I'm going to add to you mostly out
of fear that I might accidentally place
it inside the piano or something
I first met Taylor sometime in late 2008
early 2009 when a mutual friend of ours
Rachelle Garnier called me and said hey
we're doing this reading for a new play
and we need someone to play piano for
the for the musical numbers in the play
and I luckily was free and thus began a
great collaboration that would change my
life we created the Lily's revenge which
was a five hour play which somehow now
seems like some kind of warm-up
and and we followed that up with with
with touring a show that if it was a
cabaret show that was Taylor's first
ever cabaret show I believe because
before that used to just do originals
and the thing about Taylor is when
something catches your interest you're
hooked and want to make it bigger and
bigger and bigger and Taylor said to me
on a plane thinking of doing a 24-hour
cabaret show and I was like good luck
with that but somewhere in the back of
my mind I knew that I was deeply deeply
interested in that and so here we are
today I just wanted to say I have a
great love for American music and also a
great fascination with American history
when it's removed from a paternalistic
storytelling structure and instead is
viewed through the eyes of the people
who actually lived at history viewed
through the eyes of people whose stories
and experiences we have we have to
conjure and unearth we aim to do that
with this show I'd like to thank
ambassador Kennedy Smith Tony Kushner
the Columbia University Libraries the
Board of Governors and the judges for
recognizing our work and for
understanding that our intentions with
this work were and are to create
community stimulate dialogue and honor
things about America that we already
know in our bones but that have been
forgotten dismissed or buried thank you
for this prize I'm so deeply honored as
I know Taylor is to receive this
especially since it's an award with Ted
Kennedy's name on it I know I have
health insurance because of that man and
many of us are so grateful for the great
work that he did there's a long list of
people I'm sure we could both thank
including pomegranate hearts and and
machine dazzle who's here today who
helped create the show at us Nigel Smith
who's here alone and who along with
Jocelyn Clarke holed up with us some
Sundance and then went on to do
wonderful work with us in helping shape
the show I just want to say to you
Taylor
it's hard to overstate how much you and
this project have changed me for the
better when you work with Taylor you
learn how to trust delegate listen and
practice the kind of fierce flexibility
this particular project allowed me to
utilize all the skills I found over the
years being a professional musician all
at once at all times it was rewarding it
was awesome and sometimes terrifying but
always deep and meaningful you're going
to collaborator and inspire a dreamer a
righteous fighter and a true friend
thank you for trusting me and I'm so
grateful we can be up here together
receiving this amazing prize so thank
you for allowing me to say that
[Applause]
we're going to sing a song from the show
uh what uh John I wanna okay no I'm just
going to sing it all talking a little
bit here we go although I'm so although
there's no one party
all along by the telephone waiting for
I lay my in the moonlight all alone
feeling blue wondering where you are and
if you too
so in Berlin wrote this song and he grew
up in the Jewish tenements in New York
City he when he was growing up he had
people all around him at all times
I hear the giggles wha actually let's
just listen to Matt play for a little
while and then I'll tell you
[Music]
[Applause]
that way
so there are people all around Irving
Berlin in the tenement growing up and
then he moved away from the tenement and
he wrote a song called all alone having
lived a life where he was never alone so
this is what we're going to do we're
going to create a Jewish tenement here
in Columbia all right so you people
right here just in this section you're
going to be the babies in the Jewish
tenement so when I go like this you're
gonna go make baby noises if I go like
this you get louder if I go like that
you stop all right great
all right now you guys over here you're
going to all be the brothers and sisters
of the Jewish tenement okay so you're
going to be saying stuff like mom
Jimmy's bugging me
I said his talk to me stop poking me
stuff like that you can make it up ready
here we go do it go for it when it's
good yeah
if I go like that you get louder oh my
god I got you stop gorgeous okay
you guys are going to be the neighbor
kids and the cousins that have come over
and you're saying stuff like hey hey
watch me do my eyeball trick yeah you're
a little hyperactive okay so um you know
hey what's going on what's going on okay
you guys go for it go for it go for it
Atta louder okay there's a couple guys
that are like oh all right
so you guys over here you're going to be
the mom right here especially you did
all right you're gonna be the moms and
you and because I don't do things like
the heteronormative narrative I change
things up so you're going to be watching
or listening to the radio you know what
listen to the game so you're using hey
where's my beer where's my beer give me
my beer see stuff like that to me yeah
all right yeah louder okay good now you
got to stop ten when I tell
okay now you guys I hear you're going to
be the father's you're working in the
kitchen okay making them in so you're
saying stuff like like Jimmy stop
popping your sister hi there what do you
stop that but I have to sleep all day
you know that kind of stuff okay ready
go for it okay oh good all right all
right good all right now finally you
guys you're going to be the grandmas in
the grandpas and you just complain about
your ailments so or you could just go
but we're stuff like my sciatica or
whatever okay so here go for it all
right gorgeous I love this thing where
it's like I'm reading the program so I
don't have to do it you don't get a
program anymore alright so we're going
to do a little practice round I'm going
to conduct you I'm going to stand in the
center here alright little practice
round I'll conduct you and you do your
part whoo I might have to spend my part
of the money on my broken body if I fall
off okay ready when I conduct and don't
stop until you see me go like that to
your section okay there we go
that's just going to play just a little
bit while we do a practice round
[Music]
okay okay okay okay you guys doc you got
it okay here we go from the top I'm so
there is no one else part you know by
the telephone waiting oh oh oh
Oh
wondering where and how and if you
[Music]
[Applause]
mother thank you everybody thank you
thank you all your wonderful people but
I'm too embarrassed to say your names
and thank you very much to our big team
you were incredible that's it we're done
I didn't want to read one quick thing
it's actually just one little sentence
it's hoped the very last page of the
decades history a 24 decade history of
popular music
we're Taylor and Matt offered the
audience have the audience seeing a
choice which seemed to me so perfect for
the moment that we're in they say three
times or sing to be done lie down or get
up and play lie down or get up and play
lie down or get up and play so I thought
those are good words to end with thank
you all for coming
you